[Music]
everyone that's a Steve watch up with
Collider I we are here at the collider
studio at the Kia Telluride supper sweet
naturally damn oh I want to give a huge
thank you to Kia for being a great
sponsor obviously you all know covering
Sundance's costly and who's a huge thank
you to sponsor key yeah I'm here with
everyone from Palm Springs which
premieres tomorrow here at Sundance so
as I was saying off-camera you came in a
day early to party yes
that wasn't our intention but that is
what happens yeah it was some of our
intentions oh really
some of ours intention help I normally
don't ask the generic question but
everyone watching this right now will
have not seen the movie yet so how have
you been describing the friend
how have you been describing the film to
like friends and family film is a
surreal romantic comedy that's a little
subversive what you would expect for
romantic comedy with those genre tropes
and it's about Andy plays a boyfriend of
a bridesmaid who goes to this wedding in
Palm Springs he doesn't want to be there
Kristen plays the maid of honor and she
doesn't want to be there either they
find each other there's a little bit of
an odd connection and then some chaos
happens an existential hedging little
bizarre yeah I read that in the in the
synopsis it it definitely does not sound
like the typical quote-unquote romantic
comedy or anything like a genre that
I've seen before yeah it seems like
there's something new to this hopefully
we think or is it that there are a lot
of things you've seen before but never
combined that could be true hmm that is
my low bar a bully a base of sorts yeah
you obviously film all year on on a TV
show yes
so as this Camilla right so when you are
filming all year and you finally have
that little bit of a hiatus yeah it's
like do you want to work or do you want
to actually enjoy your vacation so what
was it about the
script for both of you that said I want
to do this I just rarely read feature
scripts that are sent specifically to me
where I'm being asked to be in them that
I really like there's a lot of scripts I
read that I'm like I would love to be in
that they're like they don't want you
for that yeah but this was one where
they actively wanted me for it and I
actively wanted to do it and it does
just happen so infrequently I said we
should go for it um I mean I'm the
opposite I think hiatus is the time to
really work
I think riverdale like ten months out of
the year that to me is like my than my
normal you know what I mean like it's
kind of like I'm comfortable in that
life now that's scheduled so to me
hiatus is kind of like all right it's
game time like what can I do in these
two months that will like make you know
that we're carrying me through to the
next year in blah blah blah by the way
it's crazy that that shoot is ten months
I know I mean yeah because most for
people that don't realize most shows are
not ten months no and and it's kind of
like well we're probably the last teen
show to ever be that long because now
the teen shows are like ten episodes
eight episodes and so we're still doing
the 22 order every grow up in a tangent
but a lot of people it's a lot yeah the
22 episodes and I think all of you guys
are familiar it's it's all-encompassing
yeah and I don't think people realize
the hours that it takes to make any TV
show and or to make a movie that's just
the what really goes on behind the
scenes so which leads me to what was it
like actually making this movie was this
one of these shoots that you guys had
like a blast on or were you like all
sharing pulling you know you know stuff
because of it you know a small crew I
mean it was a blast but it was a
grueling like schedule and we were
outside at night night in the desert in
like summer clothes all the time and
like holding for sand storms and like it
just was brute it was boats and sand
worms yeah but it was it was it was
yeah it was also a blast I mean I
laughed so hard she's miserable but I
had so much fun yeah you're just doing
like very ambitious stuff every day the
script is jam-packed yeah a lot of fun
things every sequence is pretty inspired
and I mean every scene is so it should
we just had to got everything which I'm
super proud of more everybody really
stepped up and elevated and there was a
ton of laughing it's like costumes I
feel like there were so many people to
like riff off of yeah yeah well one of
the things I'm curious what it's like
because clearly you guys are clearly
funny and can improvise in the moment so
how it must be great to sort of have a
script that is good and then you can
elevate it with off-the-cuff remarks
yeah yeah when it when it felt right
there were certain scenes that we kind
of treated more like the script was
Scripture and then other scenes where it
was very clear that it was a place to
play around with it yeah talk a little
bit about how long you have been
actually working on this thing I'm
hoping to get it going okay so max and I
we went to film school together
voice of Andy see Arthur right Yeah
right after we finished I was
simultaneously doing this and working on
this little-known but much-loved show
Lodge 49 and so I was on that for three
and a half years and while I was doing
that I was also writing the script in my
free time and tossing ideas back and
forth of Max and then yeah then you know
last last April we kind of finished it
and sent it out but I was like so in
from the beginning it's like a four year
process of doing this little silly witch
in Hollywood is overnight yeah yeah I
mean for an indie especially that's not
that bad 100% it's felt like it have
been very very quick yeah Oh from
finishing the script actually a moment
from when we met to the editing room is
ultimately the final rewrite talk a
little bit about what you learned when
you started cutting and maybe if you
guys saw it and then did you see it be
fly kit when it was in the editing room
D or do you typically avoid until it's
finally done I did a pass at
my director's cut and thought I knew the
meaning of killing your darlings and
it's like a whole new it's a it I
learned a lot about that about how much
you should actually leave on the cutting
room floor because rhythm especially
movie like this is everything in and II
was super involved too and yeah well my
company produced it so I was also
involved in the editing a lot and it was
fun to cut it was difficult with all the
schedule stuff but but we got a do a
place I feel like everyone's pretty
stoked I did a past two that was just
fart sounds whenever anyone took a step
and I thought that it had something and
I was outvoted
I feel like isn't there that actual
option on the without American summer
DVD they did a far pass really one of
the most like crazy sequences from John
wick three and then every time someone
makes a move there's a friend anytime
there's a point-blank range gunshot I
see there's a lot of movement I know it
took a long time I was only gonna use
like a two minute clip I looked into it
I was like right after you looked into
sixty you should go online and look up
John wick with lightsabers because
someone took an action set piece and
actually added lightsabers to it yeah I
mean one of my favorite internet videos
of all time is the kid practicing with
though oh my god it's brilliant you know
the what I'm talking about he's
practicing with a broom you gotta feel
bad for that kid I think he's okay
yeah were you actually did you were you
in the editing room or I'm not Asian
alee
like I had enough time on this movie
it was tired I'm also really lazy and by
the time that like it was a long time
editing it now is there other work so I
would chime in when it was necessary for
me to chime in and we got a lot of good
music ideas from CRA you suggested a lot
of good songs from you yeah yeah I'm
just trying to talk about the stuff that
you did aside from writing a great
script which we all agree was great you
respect what was I'm always fascinated
what was the last thing that you guys
cut from before picture locking and why
that's a good question they always say
that when they're thinking like no it's
hard because we tried tried a lot of
stuff some speeches in the wedding that
were tinkered with a lot yeah yeah yeah
there's like a long set peace wedding
toasts that we ended up tightening okay
yeah thought someone else was gonna
chime in no no no did make a more
streamlined tort pass it was also uh a
tighter voted down lost tighter
falsifier footage it was just the parts
were closer together they were more
varied fights yeah understood anyway
it's four DVDs of course for all you
guys when you think back on the making
of the movie well it's like the one day
or one moment that like kind of always
pops in your mind immediately there's a
we had a kind of a crazy stunt sequence
at the end of a day and that really felt
like everybody working together in a
crazy way this is when we were doing the
the Texas switching on the dance floor
and that was that was fun
that was a cool way I mean not fun to
get to that point but finishing that was
very very rewarding
I don't know
it was all fun and challenging in the
same amount for me the whole time
I think of two scenes in particular
effect you're some like thinking of the
film
one is involves a campfire and then
another one involves a crossbow so we
got that yeah yep yeah yeah yeah yeah
not really a crossbow no yeah I would
say one like the first day that we
started working with party over here
where Max and I went over to their
office it was me max Andy Keith and
Becky sitting in a room it's kind of
like Doan page by page and just making
it better it was so refreshing to know
that like we're all making the same
movie and I think you know Max and I are
the luckiest two dudes to have been for
real him real well we felt that way
except in Reverse ain't get towards you
Thanks it was what do you think should
win Best Picture
[Laughter]
when you think back on the making of the
movie what's like a day or two what's a
day or a moment you'll always remember
the first day because I think the first
thing I did
sorry my first day which wasn't the
first day no um
it was the scene where it's like all of
us there's anyone to spoil sorry yeah it
was so fun and it was the first scene oh
that was really it was also like this
and also you're like what really made me
want to play the part that day was a
blast a chaotic scene early on in the
film I want to sincerely thank you guys
for coming in I cannot wait to see the
movie tomorrow at the library at blah
I'm really sincerely looking forward to
it and seriously thank you so much for
coming in and this is your film an
acquisition title here yes yeah I hope
it sells tomorrow afternoon thank you
thank you for sharing things really do
thank you thank you thanks for having us